Well that was an awesome interview.
In the interview we followed
the seven step process, and
made sure to not skip a step.
>> If you're enrolled in Nanodegree,
make sure to check out our
career resource center.
Where you can find further resources to
help you prepare for your interviews.
>> Don't forget about the career
projects we offer in the Nanodegree.
Where students can get their resume
reviewed, their LinkedIn polished, their
cover letter critiqued, their GitHub
graded, and their interviews improved.
>> You've done a fantastic job making
it through our interview course.
But the more practice you have the
better chance you'll perform better and
get the job.
>> You really should be proud of
all you've accomplished so far.
Make sure to approach your interviews
with a positive mindset, and
don't give up.